offered washing
we shouldn't fear doing what god has
told us to do
we shouldn't fear it let me tell you
something
god said don't cook on sabbath
is this mic working
the bible tells us do not cook on
sabbath
cook that's why there's a preparation
day
an entire day
now did the bible say that god is the
same yesterday today and forever
if he kept the food fresh in the days of
the manner can he cook to keep the food
fresh today yes
whether you have a fridge or not
because god rewards obedience are you
listening to me do not cook on sabbath
now eloise says you can warm the food
but don't get cute and make it a cookish
warming are you following me just warm
it
[Music]
we're always trying to get around god
well i'm not cooking i'm warming up the
cooking no not don't cook but you can
warm it
but when god says do it do it do not be
afraid
all right